I know what you're thinking man Chris
this is a really early review that's
what you were thinking rise of the
Guardians is a new animated film and
it's a film that I went into with a lot
of skepticism because the trailers made
it look very generic very childish and I
went to this movie without much optimism
at all it basically tells this tale that
all the mythical creatures that children
are told are real when they're young
like the Easter Bunny or The Sandman the
guy who puts everyone to sleep or Jack
Frost or the boogey man all these people
are real and they're all in the middle
of some sort of interstellar war of some
kind way up there Jack Frost can control
you know the ice and the snow and
everything the tooth fairy actually does
go around and clicks teeth at night
she's not the freaky messed-up tooth
fairy from the horrible movie darkness
falls never watch darkness falls just
want to let you know don't ever watch
that movie it is so bad the boogeyman is
the main villain voiced by Jude Law and
I this guy wants to be noticed he wants
to be believed in because the kids don't
believe in him anymore they're not
afraid of him anymore
the point of this movie is that when the
kids believe in these characters they
get strength so the more kids that
believe in the Sandman the more kids
that believe in Jack Frost the more kids
that believe in the Easter Bunny these
people get more strength and they could
fight their battles and they can go
about their day and have their
adventures and everything as long as
kids still believe in them the boogeyman
starts infecting all the kids dreams he
makes them have nightmares instead of
sweet dreams he starts haunting their
lives and makes them stop believing in
all these people making all these guys
lose their powers then Jack Frost has to
find a way to step in and fix everything
and like I said the trailers are making
this movie look really generic and
stupid and childish this movie actually
has a lot of heart to it but not just
that it's actually a pretty exciting
action movie like there are a lot of
really good action scenes in this movie
and some amazing 3d effects really good
animation and a great score by Alexander
death block now I was thinking as I
watched this movie man this really looks
good like this doesn't just look like a
good kids family movie that has nice
polished CG animation like there's
actually some arty shots in this movie
like some really good cinematography
what do you know the visual consultant
is Roger Deakins my favorite
cinematographer the guy who did Skyfall
just now
wonder this movie looks fantastic I was
really impressed with a lot of the
action sequences in this movie because a
lot of scenes where Jack Frost is like
faced off against the boogeyman and
everything which sounds stupid it really
sounds stupid when I describe it now but
it was actually kind of epic like he
know he has his giant staff and it can
shoot ice beams and raised and
everything ice like a little kid right
now but that's really the point of this
movie too is that there's a nice
underlying heart to this film where as
people grow older they start to become
more cynical and that's one of the
biggest points in this movie people have
to rediscover their childhood wonderment
I'm trying to retain that youthfulness
in me where I look at things and I still
get inspired by things and I still use
my imagination everything while still
trying to be a mature adult and I think
that's one of the reasons why this movie
will appeal not to just kids but also
adults because there is a part of this
movie that seems like it's actually for
adults like you can actually watch this
movie and go man I remember when I was
young and I felt that way about things
still and it really kind of reached me
on that level and I was really surprised
by that because I went into this movie
expecting nothing movie has some
problems at times it feels a little bit
style over substance there's a good
story in it and there's a lot of heart
in it but at times it does really feel
like some really impressive action
sequences there are a lot of fun
sometimes override what could be a
little bit more character development
but to be honest it didn't falter my
enjoyment of the movie that much because
I really wasn't expecting much going
into this movie the movie has very good
voice work good CGI animation a really
good score some really good 3d as well
and you know I was actually kind of
surprised because this movie started out
and they somehow hadn't turned on the 3d
like I had my glasses on but the 3d was
not on and like no one in the theatre
even noticed like two people noted like
myself and one other guy got up and
we're like hey you know you got to turn
the 3d on they're like oh I'm sorry as
soon as it turned on like it Alou at
least went boom I was like wow that
actually is good 3d I was surprised by
this film I'm gonna give it a B+ thanks
a lot for watching guys and as always if
you liked this review then you can click
right here and get stuck man eyes with
no beard for now
[Music]